Carrie I heard another video interview
where you said I think I'm quoting him
here pretty woman was a disaster of a
car wreck before we got it made
it was everything miss and it wasn't
pretty woman I'm not picking on pretty
woman every film you know is hits goes
down and cul-de-sacs and goes off the
rails and burns up in a disastrous set
of plans every film gets rejected every
film the cast falls apart the financing
falls out the distribution falls out
again and again any the fastest I've
ever gotten this script produced and on
screen is three years and that's
considered super fast many films take a
lot longer than that so you can imagine
how many problems there were the stakes
are really high every film is a startup
it's a business it's a startup so you've
got the standalone business model where
you say I have the stakes are massively
high because I'm spending 40 20 50
million dollars that doesn't include the
marketing budget for the opening weekend
I'm bringing together 100 200 people
who've never worked together and they
must work together perfectly beginning
day one because I've got $100,000 and a
burn rate you're talking 30 languages
you've got bankers and insurers and bond
people you've got every creative
Department to talk to in their language
you've got the music people you've got
everything and you've got to keep all
this flowing quickly and viewed
beautifully in the same direction and
you're gonna make this film where you
can get the best way as a trailer for
free and risk everything on an opening
weekend these days this way you see
business model no one should ever fund
these things but they get through
because we have a big appetite for this
because it's powerful so yeah every film
that I've ever produced died a few
deaths and there are many times that
never never never came back to life
pretty woman actually answer your
question
pretty woman was optioned to a company
that went into bankruptcy and just
before it went into court I grabbed it
cashout deal where would have been lost
forever the next company option you also
couldn't get a finance and may never
cast Richard Gere past on the vellum a
couple of times before we got into
Disney and they all made him an offer he
couldn't refuse
I had Julia Roberts attached but the
studio didn't want her because she was
not known at the time there was it just
there was one there's and the timing to
make everything meet in the middle
is almost like a miracle but it finally
gets to that point and I think that in a
way I have this sort of Zen or romantic
notion that you have to fail a lot you
have to bump into a lot of walls you
have to really figure out how to get
this right and that when you do you'll
get your film bed
you